we are ten years on
from operation span and that was two or
three years after the abuse a decade ago
maggie oliver police officer turned
whistleblower lifted the lid on a dire
investigation into child sexual abuse in
rochdale and since then she's continued
to probe into its shortcomings but
they've
just hoped it would die and go away they
probably hoped i'd die and go away but
i'm not
the story was turned into a tv drama and
what happened in rochdale in part on
this estate became the most infamous
grooming case in the country the abuse
was allowed to continue after the child
witnesses weren't considered credible
and when it did reach court only two
victims were recognized out of
potentially dozens people will look at
this case
and go i remember that one that was
successful nine people went to jail what
do they have to apologize for that case
was not successful you know a man who
got a 13 year old child pregnant and we
had a fetus was out of prison in less
than two years he should have been
charged with rape
we knew he was the father of that unborn
child i believe that the authorities
took the easy road with the rochdale
case those men should be in prison for
years
even though these nine men were
convicted in 2012 10 years on police
have today apologized to three victims
about the way the case was handled
despite obvious indications that there
was a child abuse ring based here in
hayward near rochdale for too long it
wasn't properly investigated it was
often the girls arrested for being drunk
and disorderly not the men who got them
drunk and were raping them we spoke to
one victim we'll call sally
i just think the police just seen a
bunch of girls
because they weren't only me that used
to get arrested there was obviously a
lot of other people
i just think that they seeing it as we
were just basically tearaways we were
just little
and they couldn't be asked dealing with
us i think basically they thought they
know what they're doing they're going
out with them and it's their own problem
police in rochdale eventually approached
sally but only years later officers were
focusing on two particular victims and
because sally's abusers were different
men she was only considered as a witness
in the case
they said to me they recognized i was a
victim but because they was helping girl
a with her trial that they needed me to
be a witness but they'd come back
because obviously i'd say oh i know that
guy and i know this guy and this is what
happened to me and he was like
it's not about you and i was kind of
like the police officer said that yeah
he said come out of the room swear at
you yeah it was really bad and obviously
he was getting frustrated because he
didn't want me to talk about me it
wasn't my case but every time i slipped
up about me i was like i'm sorry
and i kept apologizing but i just kept
thinking why am i apologizing for
telling an officer that i was raped as a
child
sally's case was never taken up she says
after being a witness at the trial she
was intimidated by her abusers and that
too wasn't properly investigated
the greater manchester police apology
letter to sally says gmp did not
properly recognize your vulnerability as
a child and make far better attempts to
contextualize your behavior gmp could
and should have done much more to
protect you and we let you down
what happened here in rochdale became a
landmark case an eye-opening wake-up
call to authorities but campaigners say
the fact that this apology has taken 10
years to come tells you everything you
need to know about the speed and urgency
of progress in greater manchester police
they have treated the victims
with contempt they have ignored every
reasonable request
just to apologize and they have made
they have made those girls
fight
every single step of the way
police say lessons have been learned but
victims and this campaigner say the jury
is still out
jason farrell sky news